[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
today we're going to talk about one of
the coolest and most bizarre science
fiction universes ever created
jodarowski's johtoverse specifically the
meta barons if you have not seen my
video on the inkle you can check that
out here the meta barons graphic novel
is one of many that takes place in
jodarowski's enormous galactic
civilization it follows the history of
the metabaron in all his iterations as
the title is passed down from father to
son throughout the generations so the
first thing you need to know about this
story is it's very strange and very
weird i love jodorowsky's willingness
not to conform to expected narrative
structures some people may not like this
but i think it's part of what makes his
work unique you could never say it's
derivative even though it does have a
lot of dune references in particular
dune in fact was clearly the main
influence for the meta barons as
jodarowski very clearly took ideas from
his original 1970s dune script and put
them here an example of one of these
references is
in dune the bini jesuit can choose the
sex of their children they can also
manipulate their internal body chemistry
change cells alter different molecules
in the metabarians one of the
metabarians cannot have children the
normal way so his lover anarata of the
shabda ud basically the bini jesuit is
able to take a drop of blood from him
convert it into sperm and produce a sun
and this is essentially jodorowsky's
version of the conception of paul
atreides but there's also totally wild
and crazy things in this that have
nothing to do with dune such as the
emperor s genus jhana so in the jodo
verse there was this prophecy of a being
that was the union of perfect male and
female principles gather together in
perfect symbiosis this being would be
called the perfect androgyny and rule
over all the worlds of the universe so
in an attempt to fulfill this prophecy
and give birth to the perfect androgyny
emperor magellan and empress magella
with the help of the best robot surgeons
and the best human doctors conceive
janus janna a pair of conjoined twins
who rule the universe while living
inside of an egg which protects them
from any human diseases so in the
metabarents we see the birth of the
emperor s and how crazy that was
the emperor s is a really interesting
and strange character i just love the
fact that they are both male and female
and that they live in an egg it's super
weird i also love the characters tonto
and lothar who are the little robotic
characters that are actually narrating
the story and i have to mention that the
world building in this is absolutely
fantastic jodarowski has multiple
graphic novels that are set in this
universe including the techno priest and
like i mentioned the inkle there's also
a sequel to the ankle and a prequel and
there's also a sequel to the meta barons
called the meta baron which i have not
read yet but i hope to get to eventually
jodorowsky's connected universe is
actually amazing and really interesting
and the best part about this book in
particular is that the art is absolutely
fantastic juan gimenez the artist did an
absolutely fantastic job and he did have
a lot to live up to i mean jodorowsky's
book the inkle was done by mobius one of
the greatest of all time but the art in
the meta barons does not fail to impress
so i hope that i'm convincing you to
read this graphic novel because if you
enjoy science fiction and you don't mind
it being a little bit weird then i
definitely think you should give it a
try now i've said before that i'm glad
jodorowsky's dune didn't get made and i
stand by that because if he had actually
tried to make this movie and failed one
we probably would have never gotten a
david lynch dune dennyville news dune
would have probably never happened we
would have missed out on countless great
science fiction movies from the 20th
century that just wouldn't have gotten
made if jodorowsky's dune hadn't fallen
apart and the ideas weren't split
amongst its different creatives there's
a reason that they call it the most
influential film
never made let's be honest jodorowsky's
dune would have just been too weird for
a mainstream audience in the 1970s
but it's not too weird for a graphic
novel released in the 90s and it's
definitely not too weird for a graphic
novel these days a major reason to be
happy that that movie never got off the
ground is that we get these fantastic
comic books that fully teleport you to
an immersive
fantastical galactic universe full of
weird and interesting groups and
individuals with weird and interesting
stories now i don't intend to give away
too many spoilers about the plot in this
video because i really want you guys to
check out this graphic novel and i do
intend on covering more of jodorowsky's
comic book universe in the future
so definitely pick up the meta barons if
you want a fun story with cool
characters set in a really great science
fiction setting
thank you guys so much for watching if
you want more science fiction videos
check out my channel and make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas just a heads up for those of you
that may be interested my next graphic
novel the lie behind the star is
launching february 2023 you can sign up
now to get on the email mailing list to
get notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
you